welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Avengers end game closes the
original chapter of the MCU with an epic
conclusion that feels satisfying on a
lot of levels whilst this is the first
film in the 22 movie franchise that
doesn't feature any post-credit scenes
that doesn't mean that there aren't
hints towards what could happen in the
future throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the underwater earthquake
that Ocoee mentions and how it teases
the next big MCU villain this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the movie yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of the underwater earthquake
okay so the scene happens early on in
the film almost immediately after the
five-year time jump that sees the world
pretty much in ruins Black Widow is
currently the head of the Avengers and
she's called a holographic meeting to
check on the state of play not only on
earth but in the rest of the galaxy it's
during this discussion that Akaya
mentions an underwater earthquake that
recently happened off the coast of
Africa unable to really react to it
Ocoee states that there's nothing they
can do about it and that she will handle
it by not handling in addition to this
Captain America light enters the scene
and drops a line about whales in the
Hudson River which showcases that the
ocean is beginning to creep into the
more civilized areas of society to me
it's pretty clear that Marvel are indeed
teasing their next big bad with these
two lines which comes in the form of
Namor the Submariner for those who don't
know the character has been in the
Marvel Universe since 1939 and he's
played a big part in many key battles at
least as far as the comics go while some
people often compare him with Aquaman
and actually think that he has more in
common with his brother
but those who bred big arcs like Civil
War they'll know that Namor is a sort of
antihero that always puts the needs of
his people before others the first
appearance of the character pitched him
as an enemy of the US and whilst he was
eventually well received by the country
has always been this uneasy truce
between the land and his home Atlantis
unlike Aquaman at Namor doesn't really
have any ties to the surface so there's
no real reason for him to ever really
try to keep up the peace as his forces
could easily decimate the world if they
chose to to me this would make a very
fitting villain going forward and I can
definitely see the MCU wanting to cash
in on some of the hype around the
billion-dollar DC property the
Submariner would make an amazing test
for the New Avengers going forward and
whilst he would eventually end up on
their side say something like the
scrolls it would still be a great foe to
go up against obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this theory and if you
agree with it when the moon hits your
eyes like a big pizza pie that's no
morei if you love this video 3000 then
make sure you give it a thumbs up and if
you'd like to see more Avengers and game
related explanations then click my video
which breaks down how the paradox in the
film works which will be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I'd be definition you've been the best
and let's see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]